imagine if for the first time our heroes
all lost
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is no place today
thanos had his way and half of the
population of the universe has gone
everyone's doing their best to keep
their head above water but it's it's
kind of a losing battle we lost and
we're not used to losing people are kind
of still coming to grips with it
natasha is a little bit hardened from
what she's had to go through
they've truly leveled us not just
literally but morally and emotionally
there was no other way
the fans reaction to the end of infinity
war when half their favorite characters
turn to dust really was indicative of
how emotionally connected the world has
gotten to these characters the good
thing is it's always easier to build
people back up after they've been broken
down then that that's what Marvel is
great at doing its that shred of hope
everyone's looking for
we're in the endgame now
and who said no more surprises but I was
really hoping to pull off one last one
[Music]
I like this one
[Music]
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
happy one month until Avengers end game
hits theaters day and what a day it's
been this morning we got brand new
posters for Avengers in game and we just
recently got this brand-new featurette
for Avengers in game and it's pretty
intense when it starts off with Robert
Downey jr. saying imagine if what if for
the first time all of our heroes lost
which is exactly what happened at the
end of Avengers infinity war for the
first time really in any superhero movie
the heroes didn't win at the end of the
movie sure there are movies where some
heroes die but the villain always dies
as well and the heroes usually die
saving the day but that did not happen
in Avengers in game
Thanos won and he snapped away half of
the universe and they hit us right in
the fields in the beginning listening to
Peter Parker say mr. stark I don't feel
so good watching Black Panther turned to
dust
seeing Captain America struggle to stop
danos in which we all know he didn't but
notice where Robert Downey jr. is he's
in Wakanda we have never seen Tony Stark
in Wakanda this is proof right here that
he will visit Wakanda in Avengers end
game most likely for their technology we
then hear Chris Evans say everybody is
doing their best to keep their head
above water but they lost it's a losing
battle and right after we see Chris
Hemsworth who plays Thor say that people
are still coming to grips with it so
this implies that there will be at least
a little bit of time that has passed
between the snap and the events of
Avengers endgame it may not be a
five-year gap like we once thought it
was but it may be a month or so we think
got a Scarlett Johansson who says that
Black Widow is hardened from what she's
experienced and this kind of goes along
with what she said in the Empire
Magazine interview where she basically
said that Black Widow is pissed off
she's on another level now she wants to
do anything that she possibly can to
undo the snap she's an assassin and
we're gonna see that dark side of her in
Avengers endgame big part here from
Chris Evans when he says the Avengers
are leveled not just literally but
morally and emotionally and when he says
that we see Ronan wiping off blood from
his sword because he's just killed a
bunch of people this isn't normal
Hawkeye who doesn't really kill people
if it's not necessary this is Ronan
who's out for blood
so it's just like Chris even said he's
been shattered emotionally and morally
he doesn't care about not killing any
more he's going to kill people because
he's lost us
he wants answers and he wants revenge we
then have Marvel Studios President Kevin
Feige with sort of a funny twisted tease
here saying how attached emotionally we
are to the characters saying how much we
love them and then it immediately shows
footage of our heroes turning to dust
especially Peter Parker in the arms of
Tony Stark and then we have Chris Evans
talking about what we can expect to see
in Avengers in-game talking about how
Marvel is really good at building people
up he says that right now the Avengers
are broken but it's easier to build
people up when they're broken
so in this film we're obviously going to
see the Avengers in shambles they're
going to be completely broken after the
snap after they couldn't stop Thanos
from eliminating half of the universe
but with hope which will probably come
with the arrival of ant-man they can be
lifted back up so we're going to see The
Avengers completely broken which is
something that we haven't really seen
before we've seen them lose tiny little
battles but we've never really seen them
lose the war so they're going to be
completely crushed in the beginning and
they'll most likely go and try to fight
Thanos again in which they will lose
again and break even more to the point
to where they don't think there's any
hope but then ant-man pops out of the
quantum realm and tells them that it's
possible to go back in time and this is
where the hope comes in and this is
where the Avengers start to build back
up and become a team it then ends with
the same trailer footage that we've
shown before unfortunately no new scenes
in this new featurette but it is nice to
hear more about what the actors actually
think about the Avengers in Avengers
endgame at this point in time so let me
know what you think about this new
feature and let me know how excited you
are to see Avengers endgame in theaters
and just one month from today let me
know in the comments down below and
don't forget about my giveaway giving
away five imax tickets if you'd like to
enter for your chance to win all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain as always thank you
all so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
[Music]